♪ ♪
>> GOING THROUGH THE REVIEW
PERIOD, WE ARE VERY LUCKY WE
HAVE THE BEST NEGOTIATOR AT THE
TABLE IN THE PRESIDENT, IT WILL
BE A COUPLE MONTHS BEFORE
TARIFFS ON EITHER SIDE WOULD GO
INTO EFFECT AND BE IMPLEMENTED.
AND WE ARE HOPEFUL THAT CHINA
WILL DO THE RIGHT THING.
LOOK, CHINA CREATED THIS
PROBLEM, NOT PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Chris: WHITE HOUSE
SPOKESWOMAN SARAH HUCKABEE
SANDERS DESCRIBING THE STATE OF
TRADE RELATIONS BETWEEN THE U.S.
AND CHINA.
TIME TO BRING IN OUR PANEL.
STEVE HAYES OF THE WEEKLY
STANDARD.
MOLLIE HEMINGWAY FROM "THE
FEDERALIST," AND CHARLES LANE AT
"THE WASHINGTON POST."
STEVE, CHINA, I THINK IT'S FAIR
TO SAY THAT THEY STRUCK BACK
HARDER THAN PEOPLE EXPECTED,
ANNOUNCING TARIFFS ON
$50 BILLION OF U.S. EXPORTS,
INCLUDING SOYBEANS, WHICH IS
REALLY KEY, A BIG MARKET AND
CHINA FOR U.S. SOYBEANS AND ALSO
AIRCRAFT.
BUT NO DATES WERE SET AND THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION SAYS IT IS
NOT SETTING A DATE.
IT WILL GO TO A PROCESS THAT
GOES INTO MID OR LATE MAY.
ARE WE IN A TRADE WAR WITH CHINA
OR NOT?
>> WE ARE AWFUL CLOSE IF WE ARE
NOT THERE ALREADY.
THE BIG QUESTION IS WHETHER THIS
IS BLUSTER FROM THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AND A STRONG PUSH
BACK, CERTAINLY A STRONGER
PUSHBACK THAN MANY IN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION HAD ANTICIPATED.
PETER NAVARRO EXPECTED THAT HE
DIDN'T EXPECT THEM TO RETALIATE
BECAUSE THEY RECOGNIZE WE WERE
JUST TRYING TO BALANCE WITH THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION SEES AS A
TRADE IMBALANCE AND LO AND
BEHOLD WE ARE SEEING PRETTY
SERIOUS RETALIATION.
THE CHINESE WERE SMART AND
STRATEGIC ABOUT HOW THEY
RETALIATED.
IT'S VERY CLEAR THAT THEY PICKED
INDUSTRIES AND PRODUCTS THAT
HELP FUEL THE ECONOMY IN RED
STATES, WHERE DONALD TRUMP DID
WELL, STATES THAT DONALD TRUMP
WON IN.
THOSE ARE GOING TO BE
POTENTIALLY POLITICALLY PAINFUL
FOR THE PRESIDENT IF, IN FACT,
THIS GOES THROUGH.
I WOULD SAY AS SOMEONE WHO
BELIEVES IN FREE TRADE, I WAS
ENCOURAGED BY THE RHETORIC
COMING FROM THE WHITE HOUSE.
WE ARE A LONG WAY FROM THE
PRESIDENT'S DECLARATION JUST
FOUR WEEKS AGO THAT TRADE WARS
ARE GOOD AND EASY TO WIN RATED
WE ARE NOT HEARING PEOPLE LIKE
LARRY KUDLOW AND OTHERS SAYING
TRADE WARS AREN'T GOOD.
THE PRESIDENT IS A FREE TRADER.
WE WANT TO TRADE FREELY, WE JUST
DON'T WANT TO BE SCREWED IN THE
PROCESS.
>> Chris: MOLLIE, ARE WE IN A
TRADE WAR OR NOT?
SPEAK OF THE SITUATION IS FOR
THE LAST SEVERAL DECADES, THE
UNITED STATES AND OTHER GLOBAL
ENTITIES HAVE TRIED TO TREAT
CHINA LIKE ONE OF THE BIG BOYS
IN THE HOPES THAT THEY WOULD
RISE TO THE OCCASION, IF
THEY HAD A GREATER PARTICIPATION
IN THE GLOBAL ECONOMY, THEY
WOULDN'T BE DOING ALL OF THESE
HUMAN RIGHTS ABUSES, THEY
WOULDN'T CONTINUE THE UNFAIR
TRADE PRACTICES, THEY ARE
DUMPING, INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY
THEFT.
WHAT HAS HAPPENED AS THEY
HAVEN'T.
THEY HAVE BENEFITED FROM BEING
ALLOWED TO BE PART OF THAT
GLOBAL ECONOMY BUT THEY HAVEN'T
CHANGED THESE PRACTICES.
THERE IS WORSE THAN EVER.
THEY SUPPORT NORTH KOREA, THEY
HAVE GAINED QUITE A BIT AND WE
HAVE NOT GOTTEN MUCH.
I THINK WHAT PEOPLE ARE TRYING
TO DO IS PUSH BACK AGAINST SOME
OF THIS AND PEOPLE WHO DO OPPOSE
TARIFFS AND TARIFFS ARE A TAX ON
THE PEOPLE, THEY DO HAVE
ECONOMIC COSTS, THEY ALSO
ACHIEVE SOME PRESSURE AGAINST
OTHER COUNTRIES.
PEOPLE WHO DON'T THINK THAT WE
SHOULD USE TARIFFS TO FIGHT THIS
MASSIVE INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY
THEFT THAT COMES FROM CHINA
SHOULD PROBABLY COME UP WITH
OTHER GOOD WAYS TO DEAL WITH
THIS PROBLEM.
>> Chris: IT IS INTERESTING,
CHUCK, THE FUTURES ON THE
DOW JONES WERE DOWN 500 POINTS,
THE FACT THAT MARKET DROPPED 500
POINTS TODAY AND ENDED UP OFF
230 POINTS.
THAT IS A 730-POINT SWING.
CLEARLY, THE MARKET WAS
PERSUADED BY THE END OF THE DAY
THAT WE ARE NOT HEADED FOR A
TRADE WAR, AT LEAST NOT
IMMEDIATELY AND THERE IS A
POSSIBILITY THAT THIS BLUSTER
AND TALK ABOUT TARIFFS MAY END
UP IN A DEAL.
>> IF SO, I THINK THE MARKET IS
RIGHT.
THERE IS A POSSIBILITY.
BUT WE DON'T KNOW.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE PROBABLY A
FEW MONTHS TO COME TO REST ON
THIS.
I HAVE BEEN REPORTING ON THIS
FOR THE POST OVER THE LAST WEEK
TRADE FOR A LONG TIME.
WHAT STRUCK ME ABOUT MY
CONVERSATION THIS WEEK WITH
PEOPLE WHO ARE FREE TRADERS AND
WHO SUPPORT THE WTO IS HOW MANY
OF THEM, EVEN MANY DEMOCRATS,
WILL PRIVATELY SAY, THE
PRESIDENT IS DEALING WITH A REAL
PROBLEM HERE WITH RESPECT TO
CHINA.
CHINA HAS BEEN STEALING AMERICAN
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY.
CHINA BARS U.S. INVESTORS FROM
OPERATING IN CHINA, UNLESS THEY
AGREE TO TURN OVER THEIR
TECHNOLOGY.
EVEN MANY OF THESE FREE TRADERS
WERE SAYING IF IT TAKES TARIFFS
TO GET THEIR ATTENTION AND BRING
THEM TO THE TABLE, WE ARE FOR
THAT.
THE QUESTION, OF COURSE, IS ONCE
THEY ARE AT THE TABLE, WHO HAS
MORE LEVERAGE?
WHO IS GOING TO BE BETTER ABLE
TO GET TO A DEAL?
ULTIMATELY, WHAT THE PRESIDENT'S
END GAME IS, WHAT IS REAL
OBJECTIVE IS.
AND ON THAT ONE, I THINK THERE
IS STILL A LITTLE BIT OF
UNCERTAINTY.
>> Chris: THEN, THERE IS THE
SOUTHERN BORDER, AND HERE WAS
THE SECRETARY OF HOMELAND
SECURITY NIELSEN AT THE
WHITE HOUSE TODAY.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS DIRECTED
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY WORKED TOGETHER WITH
OUR GOVERNORS TO DEPLOY THE
NATIONAL GUARD TOWER SOUTHWEST
BORDER TO ASSIST THE BORDER
PATROL.
THE PRESIDENT WILL BE SENDING A
PROCLAMATION TO THAT EFFECT
TODAY.
>> Chris: MOLLIE, THERE WAS
SOME SUGGESTION, AND
JOHN ROBERTS REPORTING, THE
PRESIDENT'S REAL GOAL HERE, YES,
HE IS GOING TO SEND THE
NATIONAL GUARD, AND YES, HE
WANTS TO HELP PROTECT THE
BORDER, BUT THE REAL POINT HERE
IS TO TRY TO PUT MORE PRESSURE
ON CONGRESS TO FINANCE THIS
WALL.
>> EVERY PRESIDENT SINCE REAGAN
HAS SENT TROOPS TO THE BORDER.
THIS IS NOT NEW.
WE DON'T HAVE SPECIFICS ON WHAT
HE'S THINKING.
BUT THIS IS A VERY POLITICALLY
SENSITIVE ISSUE AND HE KEEPS ON
TRYING TO DRAW THE CONTRAST
BETWEEN REPUBLICAN APPROACHES
AND DEMOCRATIC APPROACHES.
DEMOCRATS IN PARTICULAR FEEL
THIS IS A GOOD ISSUE FOR THEM TO
HAVE MORE LAX ENFORCEMENT OF THE
BORDER, TO ALLOW MORE PEOPLE TO
ENTER THE COUNTRY ILLEGALLY,
FOLLOW-UP WITH WITH AMNESTY
PROGRAMS WITHOUT FIXING THE
BORDER.
IT WAS A HUGE ISSUE THAT HE
SUCCEEDED -- THAT WENT WELL FOR
HIM DURING THE CAMPAIGN, TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT BORDER
ENFORCEMENT IS LAX AND THAT WE
DON'T HAVE A REALLY SENSIBLE
IMMIGRATION POLICY.
THE MORE HE CAN HIGHLIGHT THIS,
THE BETTER FOR HIM.
>> Chris: I WANT TO GET -- WE
HAVE ABOUT A MINUTE LEFT IN THE
SEGMENT -- STEVE, TO ONE MORE
THING.
THE NEWS TODAY, THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL ROBERT MUELLER
APPARENTLY TOLD THE PRESIDENT'S
LAWYERS THAT HE IS NOT THE
TARGET OF A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION, BUT HE IS THE
SUBJECT OF A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION AS PART OF AN
EFFORT TO GET THEM TO SIT DOWN
TO TESTIFY, AND THE FOCUS SEEMS
TO BE MUCH MORE ON THE ISSUE OF
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE THEN
COLLUSION WITH THE RUSSIANS.